[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
who has just been served papers for his
divorce and he doesn't know what to do
next we talk to a woman who's married to
someone with autism and she feels so
alone we talked to a married woman who's
dealing with her in-laws whoa
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show we're so glad you're
with us
it's a show about mental health and
relationships and life
good stuff the tough stuff
we're so glad you're with us um if you
want to be on the show love to have you
man we talk about relationships we talk
about mental health talk about
psychology talk about everything
education parenting all of it um give me
a shout at
1-844-693-3291 that's
three two 1-844-693-329 one or go to
johndaloni.com
ask and
it you'll you'll be given a form you can
fill out that form and then it goes to
kelly and honestly i don't know what
happens after that i don't think anybody
does i prefer it that way
see
i i don't even know where that voice
came from
kelly's literally not in this room and
her voice just pipes in as though she is
the lord some say it might be i'm always
watching
exactly
ww kd what would kelly do right now
actually you can't ask that because she
may kill somebody yeah please don't ask
that question
wwkd
four more drinks okay i guess we're in
it so hey listen ben it's good to see
you man good to be here james is gone
thank god right everybody per usual
james is out with his family again so
we're glad to have you on the on the
boards man thank you
running the show all right hey um
we're gonna start off today's show a
little bit differently normally we make
jokes talk funny stuff here um
so we we record this show we're usually
about two three four weeks up ahead of
um what's going on in the world so
um
you know if there's a current event i
can't always speak on it the next day or
the next day after that right so
sometimes it's a couple weeks out in
this situation i'm glad it is
i'm glad it's a few weeks out because
these are situations that it's easy to
forget
and um
i learned this over the years of working
with folks who have lost somebody
that sometimes the most important thing
is just to pause and say somebody's name
and so as we're listening to this
there's
at least right so by the time this comes
out there may be more
um
there's at least
13 american families
that have a big giant hole in them right
now and this isn't a political statement
this isn't a drama statement so if
you're going to get your heart all in a
bunch you can just hit the little fast
forward button
and i know there are hundreds and
thousands of untold losses in
afghanistan
of afghanistan civilians
but this morning i got
a list of 13 folks and i thought it's
appropriate to just pause and say their
names
and not only see their names but
say their ages
because as i looked at this my it was
hard for me to catch my breath um
a couple days ago we lost 13 folks in a
an afghanistan event and um
man a lot of these guys these men and
women can't buy beer yet
they can't buy lottery tickets yet
kids it's too young
man it's heartbreaking
so who's gonna take a pause for a second
and honor these 13 folks
and honor their families
say a prayer for the mess that's going
on all over the place we're not gonna
blame we're not gonna yell we're not
gonna do that
i'm just gonna mention these
13 folks
marine lance corporal david espinoza 20
of
texas
marine sergeant nicole gee 23
california
marine staff sergeant darren taylor
hoover
31
utah
army staff sergeant ryan noss
23 tennessee
marine corporal hunter lopez 22
of california
marine lance corporal riley mccallum 20
wyoming
marine lance corporal dylan marola 20
from california
marine lance corporal karim nakui
20
to california
marine corps degan william tyler
23 of omaha
marine sergeant johnny rosario 25
massachusetts
marine corporal humberto sanchez 22
of indiana
marine lance corporal jared schmitz 20
missouri
navy hospital
corpsman max soviet 22
ohio
the ultimate
our hearts out your families to your
friends to your community to fellow
servicemen and women
and if i said your name wrong i'm sorry
no my heart's there
you gave the ultimate
gave the ultimate
all right let's go to uh let's kill the
phones let's go right to the phones man
let's go to eric in salt lake city hey
eric what's going on brother
hey john thanks for taking my call man
it's uh i admit it's been
probably the toughest week and a half of
my life so i'm grateful to be here you
bet man tell me about it what's going on
dude
i uh
i was recently
surprised by my wife and i
uh she served me divorce papers
uh
man week uh
not this last sunday but the week prior
and uh completely complete surprise
well it's surprising that i
i knew we were having some tough times
uh especially this last year or year and
a
half
but i uh
but there was never a conversation had
of that he was reaching that point
and we had just begun
you know about two weeks prior going
working with a therapist on some of the
stuff and so i i was really hopeful
and excited about that process and
looking forward to that and so the i
guess the timing was surprising for me
man i'm sorry that's heartbreak and
y'all got little ones
uh we do not okay it's just the two of
us we've been married 11 years
man
so what's the last couple of weeks been
like for you obviously it's been hell
man what's it what's it been like
i feel like you know my heart's been
ripped out of my chest man i i
i do not want this divorce to happen she
is
my everything the center of my universe
even though i don't always act like it
yeah
and uh it's it's
i'm just clinging grasping for some some
way to try and make sense of everything
and it's it's unfortunate that i have
family who are close that is
carrying me right now holding me up
have you talked to her
a little bit it's been limited i've had
a couple conversations with her mostly
logistical stuff but we did have a
chance to meet together briefly with the
you know church leader for example how's
that
is she done done done done
her words were
well the time she served papers she said
she was done done done
during that uh meeting with my our
ecclesiastical leader
i asked her for the opportunity just to
try working out through that process
with a therapist and she didn't actually
give me an answer at that point and so
uh the answer is i'm not sure i'm
getting some mixed signals yeah i
i know in these kind of moments
especially as you're walking through
just an onslaught of grief
um
you're gonna read the signals that best
fit
the hole in your heart
and um i would let the
divorce papers that she served you ring
loud and clear obviously don't
you know don't give up if that if you
want to stay married and continue to be
kind and treat her with dignity and
respect and love that of course you will
um but also don't imagine a scenario
that may not be real right
yeah would she meet with you one-on-one
at a coffee shop
uh you know i don't know if she would
today but i think if i i do believe that
she would we can get to that point
before all this officially completes
yeah i think you would is that a is that
mythological thinking or fantasy
thinking or is um like if she would meet
with you today
what
what would happen between now and a few
weeks from now that would change that
during some of our logistical
conversations we've had i think
logistical meaning you know
budget things and process right she she
she's showing signs i think of softening
uh you know not not
big grand conversations and and a couple
days ago she even gave me a hug
because of something going on and just
little
i'd like to think that that would that
she would meet with me to have a
conversation like that okay um but i
admit i i also accept that i'm an
emotional i'm an emotional roller
coaster that's right yeah and so and and
here hear me say um what i don't want to
do is is
you're going to look for every sign that
this thing may still have a heartbeat
right
and sometimes we get our signals crossed
there because she may be finally
breathing for the first time she had
been thinking about this for one year
two years three years and she finally
may be exhaling for the first time
in years and so a hug for her may be
a sense of finality and for you it may
feel like oh so you're telling me
there's a chance right so
you can you can cross each other in the
night
um that's why
for your soul and we haven't even got to
the question i just don't even know why
you called but uh i just started talking
but
for your soul
sitting down and saying can we meet
and be
not beating around the bush i think
there's still some
be very clear um
you filed papers and have you had a
we've had some a couple of weeks now to
be working on logistics is there a
chance that we don't go through with
this
and let her speak very clearly and with
the period at the end of that sentence
otherwise you're good it's going to be
this
hanging on weird thing right it's like
being in love with somebody who's on
life support and every day is an up day
and a down day it's going to feel like
this roller coaster and you've got an
opportunity to cut through the middle of
it and if she won't meet with you that's
a great answer right
yup that's a firm decision answer but i
think if if your marriage is going to
make it um
having a conversation at the beginning
or not the beginning but here at the
beginning of the end if you will um
is is a good way to get some clarity but
i just cut you off man so how can i help
today man i'm so sorry you're going
through this i appreciate john and i
between us i am spraying my guts out and
working hard to make sure that uh
if there is a way of salvaging it that
that's my first priority but my the
question i was calling about was my i've
been with my best friend and closest
intimate partner for 11 years
and and the thing i fear the most
is
being
alone again when all this is over yeah
and and and being entirely
uh on my own you know economically
spiritually
we're okay we're big you know we've
we've been debt-free dave ramsey fans
for a long long time and we've set up a
really amazing life
but just that thought of being alone
without without her in my world just
terrifies me so the question is how do i
go about
finding a sense of normalcy and learning
to heal and basically how do i continue
my life after
uh such a long time of being a partner
with somebody and not having that
anymore that's a great question
um
i think the most important thing to do
is to mourn this like a death
we hear about divorce all the time
and it's so common that we forget how
brutal and painful and gut-wrenching it
is
for a thousand different reasons you're
in a fortunate situation where your your
finances are fine you know what i mean
there's not kids involved it's and i say
you're fortunate there's there's there's
less layers here
and you're just feeling the emotional oh
my gosh i'm gonna wake up i'm gonna come
home to an empty house foreseeably
you know for the next who right i'm
gonna come to an empty house right and
so it's owning the fact that this is
common and everybody talks about it we
all have friends whose parents got
divorced
you gotta mourn this like a death
right and so
um this is not a
an event this is a process
and healing is gonna look different for
everybody and it's gonna look different
in different seasons for different
people
but for you man knowing i gotta honor
this thing because it's gonna come over
me like i'm i'm out in the middle of the
ocean
right
yeah um
grief will wave over you and it will
feel like i can't breathe and i'm not
gonna be able to i'm gonna drown and
you're not you're not it's gonna feel
like it
um and then you're gonna have all sorts
of the shame and the guilt and the
you know what i mean and the failure and
all the stuff you're going to feel as
you
navigate through this and you're going
to get really pissed off you're going to
be angry and you're going to want to go
rage all those things are going to be
normal part of this grieving process
but it's knowing i'm in this for a
season this isn't something i'm gonna do
in a couple of weeks then i'm gonna be
up and at them does that make sense
yes sir and at the same time you're
gonna have to be up and at them you're
gonna have to eat you're gonna have to
sleep you're gonna take care of your
body you're gonna have to be around
other people right um do you have some
people that are going to walk through
this with you you have a group of guys
that are ride or die that you've had for
a while in your life they're going to be
able to come over at 2 a.m and bring
taco bell and
who are also going to come over 2am and
make sure you're not having your
fifth helping a taco bell right you have
a group of guys going to walk through
you with this
you know i do but it's complicated she
and i have been married so long her
friends are my friends my friends are
hers
and
and it's i'm trying so hard to respect
you know the boundaries and and and i
guess what my fear is is that by
bringing people in that i'll be
betraying her trust because i certainly
have no intention of throwing her under
the bus sure for anybody so and those
relationships why would you be betraying
her trust tell me about that
well
she she's had a difficult time getting
friends over the years and and my
closest friends because they're around
are the only real friends she has in her
world sure and what i don't want to
happen is for her to feel like
uh
the world is gathered against her so
eric she
you love this woman
and i take it that she's a good human
being
and she made a grown-up decision
yes
right
and my hope is that she made a grown-up
decision she thought it all the way
through from start to finish
and
my hope is that when she held those
papers and
saw you she thought whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
probably not probably not
um
but you can't not have people in your
life especially people who have been
your friends for years and years and
years your go-to people you can't choose
to isolate yourself in this moment
because of some things that maybe it
might be this might be
that's the wrong way to think about it
she's made up grown-up decisions she's
gonna have to reach out to her community
you're gonna have to reach out to yours
and if they happen to overlap they
happen to overlap right
what i'm telling you is you cannot do
this by yourself
yep right you can't
you got to be really intentional about
your life
can i ask you a hard question
i welcome it go for it uh what part of
this do you got to own
i have a lot to own john tell me about
it
oh man what that's a big question my
friend it's uh rattle them off you got
them you've been thinking about them for
the last two months
i've been
i've had i've really dealt with some
significant depression
uh
i've been battling uh
battling honesty issues okay
being honest with her
um
that includes a lot of empty promises
you know a lot she's heard a hundred
times i'm gonna get i'm gonna admit i'm
gonna i'm gonna get this taken care of
this time and i meant it in the moment i
didn't have the tools or the skills
uh or or
yeah and it didn't follow through okay
uh and probably most significantly i
think
is i'm as i've been meditating lately i
think i've
i may have been emotionally bullying her
uh
unintentionally but i feel i think i've
been smothering her emotionally
uh
for a long time
yeah i think so okay i think so
so and i and something that she's been
trying to articulate and i just couldn't
connect the dots until i had a family
member holding my feet to fire and
walked me through it and i had an aha
moment and i realized how stupid i've
been
so
assuming this is over
there's two choices and i hate to
bifurcate the world like this but i'm
going to you got two choices
you can choose to sit in
and stew in
and try to
rewrite
sentences of the past with the period at
the end of them
which does no but any good
or you can take this
as the greatest sign of your life that
now i'm gonna deal with me
that i'm worth not
not living a life of depression under
those heavy heavy blankets and i'm gonna
go get healing
that i'm gonna learn how to connect with
folks and not drag them around by their
emotions and their hearts
and um i'm also going to find out how to
have peace with the guy in the mirror
because that guy's worth being loved
deeply right
yeah
and choosing to
spend the next two years five years 10
years
not grieving this because you're going
to grieve it you're probably always
going to love this woman right she
sounds like she's pretty special is that
is that fair
the best thing in my universe absolutely
okay
so
you can spend the next 5 10 15 20 years
um mourning this missing her and you
probably will and you may find love
again and you're still gonna have a
thing for her in your heart you always
will
but you can spend 10 or 15 years just
lashing yourself beating yourself up
sentencing yourself to a life of further
misery
or you can say i'm going to be
intentional about my life i'm going to
own the parts i'm going to change my
identity i'm going to do the hard work
i'm going to go see a counselor i've
been saying i'm going to for years i'm
finally going to do it
i'm gonna start taking care of my body
i've been saying it for years i'm
finally gonna do it
i'm going to be intentional about being
honest with people and telling the truth
for the first time in my life
because i deserve that the people who
love me deserve that and
some of that is going to start as simple
as
something cheesy that i do every day
which is a gratitude journal which is
getting an index card saying here's what
i can control today
right it's getting teeny tiny
little bits of myself back
and it's a practice and you're going to
do really good for a month you're going
to fall off you're going to get back up
the next day you're going to go again
you're going to go again and you're
going to go again
but listen eric
you're worth being well you're worth not
living a life under that cloud of
depression
and you're worth telling the truth
right is it do you believe me
absolutely okay
this one may be over
i hope it's not man i hope you'll keep
in touch with me i hope you'll reach out
to her and say can we meet just you and
me
and if she says no
obviously you're gonna treat her with
respect and you're gonna honor her
wishes right
if she does
you can tell her where you're at and you
can also let her know hey i know i've
said this a million times and i've never
followed through
and this one's going to be different and
by the way here is my
here's my meeting with i mean my my
appointment with the therapist here's my
this and here's my that
um but more importantly not to try to
win her back or to try to make sure she
like
no man get healing for you
and then you can fully plug into
somebody else not through emotional
manipulation not through feeling
manipulation but connected to somebody
of value love somebody of value
somebody wakes up every day trying to
support somebody else somebody's going
to be totally honest because what you
say what you feel what you believe has
value
now because you got to try to hem-haul
around things and there's no chance on
planet earth that she's blameless in
this deal too right so she's gonna have
to own herself also but this is a a
process not an event
you gotta have people and you're gonna
have to mourn this thing you have to
take it seriously
don't race to move on and on those
moments when the when the waves crash
over you
and you can't breathe hang in there
hang in there
you're not gonna drown
you're gonna catch a breath back your
body's gonna resurface
and you're gonna have to have some
people with you you're gonna go again
you're gonna go again and you're gonna
go again
so sorry going through this eric man um
we'll be thinking about you let let us
know how that conversation goes and
we're gonna hold out hope for you um
and then we're gonna walk alongside you
man so if she says no let us know that
too and holler back after the divorce is
final and we'll walk you through day one
day 10
day 180 and we'll keep going from there
all right i want you to reach out to
somebody today and make sure you've got
somebody that's going to walk with you
through this thanks for the call man hey
uh we'll be right back on the dr john
deloney show
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important your
mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy for you video
chat phone or even text chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you become a better version of
yourself help you get on the road to
being well go to
betterhelp.com for 10 off your first
month this is less expensive than
traditional therapy and you're worth it
betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right we're back let's go to cassie
in kansas city hey cassie what's going
on
hi dr dalony thank you so much for
taking my call i watch all your videos
and you have helped me in many many
areas i appreciate that there's gonna be
some uh
i'm not very good at this so thanks for
being one of the few people that watch
those videos how can i help you what's
going on okay so um
my long-term marriage is neurodiverse
um which we just found out a few years
ago
our relationship has really passed the
stage of resentment which i know you say
once you get there
it's harder to come back yeah yeah so we
have basically just been really good
roommates for a while okay um when you
say neurodiverse do you have a does you
have personality disorders you have
autism or a traumatic brain injury
what's he got um so he is on the uh on
the spectrum okay how
where
i i mean if
you'll have to forgive me because i
don't i'm not familiar with the
terminology a ton but um
the outdated thing but that's what we
were told at the time cool yeah we're
hey everybody's doing the best they can
with the tools they got so it's you're
not gonna hear me hating on you um so
he's he's high functioning at this point
absolutely okay all right so um you
found this out win a couple years ago
yes it's been about four or five years
ago
and what steps has have you all taken
together has he taken
what's the last four or five years been
like
very
i can't say they've been easy
they have been
it was rough before that and
if i had to be honest i would say that
the diagnosis was almost
more disheartening than it was
encouraging
because
because beforehand anything that
hurt my feelings or i didn't understand
i could blame it on
uh his childhood um on the aces score
he's a six he didn't have a great one
yep um
he was never held as a kid i've never
seen his parents have him to this day
sure um so i thought i could blame it on
the fact that he just didn't know better
and
i could eventually teach him
what i needed
but the reality is a lot of those things
are
because because of
his asperger's because
of the autism
and i didn't know that until i could
read it and i could read articles and
and then it would just smack me in the
face oh my gosh this is
somebody else knows exactly how i've
been feeling
but but
but uh
i know you're hurting can i be super
honest with you though and i'm not
trying to be mean okay no that's okay
trying to be direct um
i need it
the way you just phrased that or the way
i heard it was i would rather
him
be ignorant
or
unwilling
than to have some biological challenges
and the idea that you cannot teach
somebody with who's a high functioning
autistic adult
ways that they can love you better is
inaccurate
absolutely totally you can and so
whether it's childhood trauma whether it
is just knuckle-headed [ __ ] idiot dude
who's just like no i don't know what
or
somebody with um
some neurological challenges that may
not ever
connect with your feelings but knows
that these feelings are real and that
you are having them and this is the way
that i can best love her in these
moments
man
there's there's choice and chance all
across that thing so what i hear you
saying is after the last four or five
years have you given up on him or has he
said i'm not trying
no absolutely not
i would say at the beginning
um i i
i guess i should have said a pleasant
spot with that's how i feel now looking
back at it at the time i was like okay
if i can just explain these things in a
different way
um
something may click
and now i know if you say something
hurtful
then it's really not
i need to not take it so personally and
then explain to you why that hurts my
feelings yes um and then maybe it won't
happen again or i can explain to you
what i need
and
to be 100 honest i feel like that's
that's hard to do
that's hard to have to tell somebody how
to love you it is it's hard
yeah
it's real hard
and you want to be able to
you want to be able to walk home from
work and walk in the door and they look
across the room and the music swells and
he sees you you know and he knows what
you need right i'm being totally honest
right totally honest and that's not
something like that in just
non-typical neurological families that's
in every marriage i've ever heard in my
life right
um
so but i
it is painful and it's exhausting and it
feels lonely and hollow right
i couldn't have put it in better words
that's for sure how i felt for a very
long time okay
so
do you want to stay married
you sound like you're done
i feel like i wouldn't be calling you if
i was done maybe okay um
i feel like
i'm just
i'm just
desperate because i feel
like i know we can do this i know we can
do this and i
just don't have the tools to do it and
the people that i reach out to the we've
gone to marriage therapy um we've gone
to marriage counseling um he's he's seen
a therapist on his own um
we have just had bad luck after bad luck
as far as that's concerned
to where they're either
um
it's not really their forte like they
come at our marriage with a neurotypical
mindset and that's not helpful or um one
in particular that we went to see um
told me that i just needed to learn how
to live in an autistic world and that
didn't ring true to my heart either
because the truth is this isn't uh you
know regular life isn't going to change
for him
and i don't mind um
i that sounds horrible
no it doesn't matter
here's the thing i um
i guess i would refute that
and there can be some autism specialists
that um
can write in i'd love to i'd love to be
shown i'm wrong here
my experience which is uh you know
admittedly limited
is
it is equally lonely and hollow living
inside an autistic mind
and while they may not be able to
um
experience some of the same experiences
that a neurotypical person might i don't
even know what that means anymore but
what i know what you might feel right
they do
they can experience
the joy the pleasure of knowing that
they are caring for somebody in a way
that that person has asked to be cared
for
i've seen it
and it's really remarkable
and i've also worked with folks who have
to remember oh this is when i make that
smile on my face because that brings joy
to the people around me and this is when
i raise my eyebrows and say wow
but that in and of itself is an
expression that attempt that try that
leaning into
is such a
um
it's such a powerful expression of love
even though it looks different does that
make sense
absolutely
and so
i do get 100
that the hollywood version of this is
over right and it is it can be so lonely
and you say all the time you know have a
funeral for it
believe me i had
i was already there
you know
that
i'm not i'm never going to have the
husband who writes me a love song or
accept himself because that's not my
husband except
if you said
once a month i need you to write me a
love poem
and you are allowed to use somebody
else's lyrics
and then you would know
how non-intuitive that is how hard that
is what a challenge that will be
and he'll do it anyway
and what you're gonna have to do is
decide just because it's on his calendar
it doesn't mean less
and just because um he doesn't have long
hair like fabio and he's holding i can't
believe it's not butter and he's not
writing a dragon or whatever that it's
still romantic even though it looks
different does that make sense
it's a hundred percent make sense and so
it's it's coming to and here's the thing
in completely
neurotypical couples
the idea of putting sex on a calendar
is always this like everyone feels like
well if we have to put on the calendar
then we should even be married and i
just called bullcrap on that
if we have to plan dates they're not
really dates stupid yes they are does
that make sense
none of this looks like hollywood right
and so
oh no
it has never it has never looked like
all of this um it never has and i and i
don't and i don't have dreams of it
looking like hollywood oh i know i know
right now i'm speaking to everybody
right you're way past that i know i know
you're way way past that here so
have you sat down and you may have done
this
have you sat down and said every sunday
night
that will be
our planning for the week and we're
gonna plan our budget we're gonna plan
our calendar
and we're gonna plan my needs
because here's what i'm telling you if
every married couple on planet earth did
this the world would look very different
in a positive direction
if everybody sat down and said here's
what i need right now here's what i need
this week here's the hands motion i need
when i am
saying something that's hurting your
feeling my wife and i have had these
conversations recently
because she's going through some shifts
that are setting some of my old alarms
off in a way we've been together for 25
years and i i didn't know we're there
and i had to say
when i start responding like this i need
you to just reach your arm out and then
i'll know
and she's like got it and she's done it
twice it's been amazing right but it's
that lo and it feels so on jack and rose
right like i just we're supposed we saw
each other in the titanic it's just
supposed to be this is not how it's
working so if you had that conversation
would he love you enough to lean into it
we have had many of those conversations
um
for an example uh
our intimacy there just isn't any any
anymore okay but
have you said i need sex three times a
week and i need it like this
i need dress up night this night i need
music night this night i need old boring
married sex on this night have you done
that
i have said
i need
10 minutes of your undivided attention
every night after the kids go to bed
okay
and what is that undivided attention is
amorphous for me
so have you said i need 10 minutes of
you holding my hand
and i want you to take off your shirt
and i just want to hug you skin-to-skin
or i want you just to listen to me
chit-chat
like what have you been specific
and the reason i'm saying that is is
that i've had to do that in my own
marriage
every couple i work with has to end up
there when they're on marriages and i'm
trying to tell you you're not crazy
but it is gonna take a heightened level
of and i'm not trying to say that your
marriage is typical it's not you've got
some deep challenges in this thing
but you're gonna have to get that
specific and that specificity
can become really erotic
and really fun and really directive does
that make sense
it does
am i crazy
you're not crazy
for me i thought
i mean for months i asked for i just
need a deeper connection with you i just
want to me and you to have a
relationship again i just want to like
check in how are you doing how am i
doing how you feeling what's going on in
your world
i want to i want to i i wanted that and
and then that didn't work out very well
so then it got to just come and let's
talk for 10 minutes
and apparently what i hear you saying is
i need to be even more specific than
give me 10 minutes of your time each
night i when you say that to me as a
husband i don't know what that means
like i i i is that chit chat time do you
want to go french kiss for a while do
you want me just to sit there and nod
you want me to fix i i don't know what
that means i think there's a scenario
here
where you could have a blast
coming up with a
weekly marriage worksheet
that your autistic husband is going to
check off how is your day today did you
have mostly positive um things happen at
work did you have negative things happen
at work what made it what made you sad
what made you
experience joy and y'all check this
worksheet off together is that
ridiculous yes is that intimate yes
and so what i'm telling you is
there and that's why i asked are you
done because what it feels like is
that level of intentionality
that can how long have you been married
16 years there you go every 16 year old
marriage i know is in this boat
not as deep as yours yours is unique
hear me say that
but every 16 year old marriage i know of
starts speaking in i just miss the old
us or we just aren't having sex like we
used to or the kids are and it becomes
this speaking in generalities in these
big grandiose pictures
and everybody starts you've heard me say
this over and over i'll say it again
we think in pictures but we
but we speak in words
and so when you say i just need 10
minutes of your undivided attention
he has a picture in his head of what
that looks like
and you do too and you're missing each
other because your pictures are
different you're both using the same
words and he thinks he's doing right
or when you say
i need sex this week he says great and
his picture is six minutes and we're
done and your picture is i just need
some glass of wine and the music i need
the kids to disappear and i need it to
be like we were dating right does that
make sense
absolutely so it's that level of it's
not less romantic and in fact if you can
get into the head part of this the
desire and the eroticism part of this
and let your head go crazy about the guy
that you love
it can be real fun
and you can begin to practice desire
with specificity
and you can practice desire with
explicit here's what i need here is what
connection looks like and i haven't met
i
i haven't again admittedly i haven't
worked with a ton of folks with autism
but the high functioning adult autistic
folks that i've had a chance to to work
with
love
that level of specificity and the guys
i've been around the men and women
around
are all in
right because they want so badly to
connect
and i would really
recommend you give that a shot high
levels of specificity say beginning this
week we have a sunday night meeting you
and me no kids they're off whatever
whatever and we're gonna plan the week
we're gonna plan love we're gonna plan
budget we're gonna plan
uh i don't know calendars and we're
gonna start from there
and then start being as
specific as possible and if you can
co-create a worksheet together
co-create the calendar together and say
these two nights are sex nights
this night is hugging night
and i want 30 minutes of hugging and i
want you to wear these clothes
yeah i know it's different it's never
been in a hollywood maybe it has i don't
know
and here's the other thing he can learn
forgiveness and grace and he can learn
not record keeping of all your faults
which i know that's can be a challenge
in these in these type of relationships
he can practice self-awareness he can
practice being quiet practice asking
kind questions so maybe on a worksheet
you say ask me three questions about my
day
and again you're teaching and is that
your job no but is that going to help
bring you all together yes
he can learn to be gentle with the truth
right he can and and when i say that
he can say
is that what you're wearing versus a
very direct ugly comment about your
right all those things
starts with you being really intentional
and here's what i want to tell you if
you feel you started this call saying
man
we've been a resentment a long time
the way out of resentment
is an all-in i'm doubling down with
intentionality that's the only way out
i'm gonna be hyper hyper hyper
intentional
and i think you can do it so here's what
i want you to do i want you to have this
meeting with him and let him speak into
it
um i don't know a lot of people who once
they say hey let's put this stuff on the
calendar that would that want to push
back
hopefully he wants to be all in too
i want you to have this meeting and then
once you write me back let me know how
that meeting went and we'll be thinking
about you along the way
get two or three or four sunday nights
into this deal
and let me know if things have changed
because my god tells me it can my god
tells me you can
but it does mean you're going to be
super specific
and you may need to go see somebody to
talk about your loneliness your anger
your
ah this looks so different but you said
you've already had the the funerals for
what was and now it's time to plan for
what could be
and i know i'm high optimistic on this
one i am i am i am i am
double down on intentionally specificity
let's see what happens
all right stay tuned we'll be right back
on the dr john dolone show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right one more let's go to sierra in
seattle washington what's up sierra
hey dr john
how are we doing i
am doing great how are you i am rocking
onto the brick of dawn what's going on
how can i help
oh man life goals fulfilled okay
listen with all due respect you've got
to set higher goals for yourself
it's awesome all right so what's up uh
no no achieve your dreams before age 30
and then
yes but
you want to shoot for the moon not for
like a medium-sized volkswagen right not
for a small car but anyway okay so
what's up how can i help hey man
all right so
um i
i have a difficult relationship with my
in-laws in particular my mother-in-law
and i know i'm totally unique
in that struggle i've never heard this
call okay so
oh my gosh i know what is unique
well so
a bunch of things
uh mostly we have very um
it's very strange to specialize as my
husband i move to the other side of the
state okay so um there's a lot of
mismatch expectations
um i see in my mother-in-law that she's
not
she doesn't respect a lot of my
boundaries a lot of my expectations for
how
like
i would like to be treated and we've
been working on it for like five years
and it's one of those things where every
time it starts to feel like we're making
some progress we get that back right
back to the very square beginning again
and she'll call my husband up and say
things like i don't know if we can
all meet up as a family you know can can
just you and the kids come visit not
like can you leave sierra at home what's
your husband say to that nonsense
no way mom that's my wife good for him
you married well
i did i did she raised a good boy
despite her nonsense
um so what what do you do that's so
terrible
fix it sierra what's wrong i'm just
kidding wait what happened
well so um i mean first of all we moved
away um we had an opportunity to you
know for my husband to pursue a career
he wanted to be in and for us to move to
a much lower cost of living area
and so we did and that means we took the
only grandkids in the family with us and
um
and you recognize that one of these
that she can't be mad at her darling
little boy and so she's got to take
swings at the next adult in line which
is you right
yeah there you go
exactly so you recognize you don't
deserve that crap too right
oh yeah no i mean we made we made the
best decision we could and frankly
looking at both sides of our families
they made that decision at one point too
and um so one of the things that really
you know has broken my heart about this
whole struggle and the fact that this
relationship has been so difficult is
i was so excited to have
two
intact sets of grandparents nearby for
my kids
because both my husband and i lived in
places where it just wasn't possible for
our grandparents to be around a ton
and so i was really really excited about
that and then we had this opportunity to
move and my family's close
but his is not they're about four hours
away so they're not like
you know it's not east coast west coast
but it's it's a waze right and so it
makes visits puts a lot of burden on
visits to be super fun and super
action-packed and super busy
and one of the one of the big sticking
points has been things like because we
moved away my in-laws
feel like it's our obligation to come to
them hey
sierra
you're not crazy
thank you and your in-laws are immature
they're jerks
and your kids deserve better than that
your husband deserves better than that
and you deserve better than that
and in your head and in your heart
it's never gonna add up
because you got two people that it makes
no sense
that they don't act like adults now
adults would be heartbroken that their
only grandkids moved away of course they
would and they would miss you like crazy
of course they would
i'm from texas four hours is your
next-door neighbor right that's not a
long time
that's a weekend
that's a we're coming to hang out and
we're just gonna head home right it's
not temper tantrum
and that if you don't see us then i
guess it because here's what's going to
happen your kids are going to make
extraordinary
wonderful intimate relationships with
your parents
and they are going to be right or die
with your parents and it's going to be
awesome
one because your parents are close two
because your parents aren't acting like
children
and they already are it's
it's awesome so special here's who's
missing out
on how many kids do you have
we have a three-year-old one-year-old
and we're another on the way yeah
awesome
here's who the big loser here is
your your husband's parents
they're the losers you know why because
they're not gonna get to meet and love
and be intimately close to three
wonderful little kids
they're gonna take their grown-up temper
tantrums and miss out on the life of
three extraordinary little kids
they're going to miss out on their son
who they raised who's a great guy who's
going to be a great dad who's a great
husband
they're going to miss out on all of that
because they're throwing grown up temper
tantrums and you
can't do anything about it
and so the hardest thing you're gonna
have to do
is mourn the fantasy of the four living
grandparents that were going to be so
great
because you got two
and anytime
anytime
a set of parents calls outside of some
abuse issues some major addiction issues
some major violation stuff
and would ever say something like
hey can you and the kids just come but
don't bring her
good for him for saying absolutely not
that's my wife
and that is the clear signal to you guys
it's time for y'all to move on and that
means you're gonna have to make your own
thanksgiving plans and your own
christmas plans and that means that you
can say things like we're having
thanksgiving dinner with our friends
here
and it's gonna be thursday at 4 pm
you're welcome to join us
and that's it
and they get to make grown-up choices
about whether they want to be in your
life and in your kid's life or not
because you guys are going to do
thanksgiving with or without
them does that make sense
yeah
and it's hard for a second
and then once you draw that boundary and
you hold it up for the first time and
it's gonna come at a big moment right
it's gonna come at some big dramatic
oh you mean you're not coming to the our
whatever halloween event
nope we're doing trick-or-treating here
you're welcome to join us that night um
we're gonna have three kids under the
age of four so we're not gonna have
y'all gonna need to get a hotel but we'd
love to have you here it'd be great
and um here's the event that we're gonna
be at and if they choose to join you
awesome awesome and if they don't they
made a grown-up choice and it's okay to
be sad
but you can't own it and you gotta it's
so trite and so silly you guys gotta set
it down
and that starts really with just
mourning it
is your husband's heart broken by all
this
is he surprised or did he sometimes this
is a big surprise when grandkids are
involved often though
like dude i grew up with these parents
because they've been acting like this
for years
yeah it was it's been an evolving thing
like when we were first married it's not
that my husband
couldn't see what was wrong but you know
he'd been in the soup for so long you
know he couldn't see quite why it was
what it was affecting me so much
so it's taken him a little while but
it's one of those things that like once
you see it you can't unsee it and so
he's he's ride or die with me for sure
and he's like you're my my future and
the mother of my babies and all of that
and so he's
he's like mom the idea of me coming for
a visit with just the kids and not my
wife is asinine i'm not doing that so
here's here's what we're done with
here's what we're done with we're done
with long dramatic phone calls
and we're done with yes we're done with
long dramatic text exchanges
we're going to move into a season of
boundaries which is going to be
information transmission okay doesn't
mean you don't love them
it means you're wasting everybody's time
by having these long
finally we're here and you hang up and
you're like finely
this adult is gonna act like an adult
they're not five years five years of
this
okay
so
yeah um what would be really awesome is
to send out here in the next 30 days you
and your husband sit down and plan it
out
send out holiday plans 2021.
here's what we're doing and send it in
an email
that's very concise we will be spending
christmas with my family on these days
uh we will both be at work so we're not
gonna be able to hang out um we will
have this weekend off if you'd like to
come visit us that would be wonderful
due to uh you don't have to give a due
to we will not be traveling this year
and we'll be doing thanksgiving at our
house and we do plan to have some
friends over and some neighbors and some
community members over we'd love to have
you too you're invited
that is it
and any dramatic email response and he
calls your husband is like can you
believe it
that's their choice
that's the that is the choice they're
making
right and this is gonna be hard on your
husband this is like making me sad
thinking about this because i always
want to honor my parents i always want
to honor the adults in my life that's
the right thing to do
and it's hard when ultimately i have to
make boundaries
and i do unfortunately i won the lottery
with my in-laws i won the lottery so but
what i'm saying
even the even in our relationships
though
boundary i mean clarity and boundaries
are super important that way it just
doesn't turn into this weird everybody's
on the same page that makes sense so
everybody's gonna win by doing this
anyway and you can send this email to
your parents too we'd love to have you
here at this time it's gonna be so great
and then you're gonna find in your home
with you and your husband and three
rambunctious bananas kids running around
one of them's not gonna be running
around one of them's gonna be yeah not
running around oh i can't believe you
have three to four that's gonna be
um oh it's gonna be so exciting well so
that's actually something i i wanted to
ask you about okay go quick we're up
against the clock go quick what do you
got sure sure so we had we just had a
visit and i know they're gonna be off my
back for a bit but the holidays are
coming and then right after the holidays
and so i'm trying to figure out and get
my head around what do i say about
meeting the new baby
whatever you want
it's your baby it's your
house it could be my mom's coming to
stay with us for three weeks to take
care of the two little ones
while i either you got to go back to
work your husband's work whatever
and we will be accepting visitors at our
house on the beginning fill in the blank
that's it
it doesn't have to be dramatic it
doesn't and obviously you're not going
to be punitive and be ugly and rude and
disrespectful
or it might be they can swing by they're
not going to be able to stay at your
house because your mom's going to be
staying there or nobody's going to be
staying there you're welcome to come
um we're not going to have any visitors
staying with us but you're welcome to
come by and hold the baby and see the
baby and do all that kind of stuff
um you can take our little kids out to
dinner um while i'm recovering or
whatever you set the boundaries it can
be whatever you want and this could be a
really
hard heartbreaking time
or it could be the you could do this
write this email with a smile on your
face
like oh my gosh i get this i this is my
baby and my house
we get to co-create imagine that yeah we
need to decide we need to decide it's up
to us it's our house right
what a cool season what a cool season
yeah
uh whenever our second child was born my
wife gave me a list
like for the hospital don't say this
these things don't ask these questions
and i was like oh oh oh ok ok
it made the everything so great it made
everything so great she sent an email
out to my mom to her mom it was
wonderful everybody was on the same page
right and there wasn't any of this weird
like do we come in do we not come in are
we coming over it was just clean as
could be it was awesome right you
you sierra get to choose
now don't fire this off without your
husband obviously sit down with him and
say here's what i'm thinking we're going
to draw the boundaries is what it's
going to look like and so you get to
dream and imagine
october november december
january you get to just make the rules
here
so great so cool
respectfully and with dignity
your life your boundaries
go from there
hopefully
hopefully
your in-laws will stand up and say
wow this is incredible good for them
good for them we're going to honor this
family this new young family we're going
to honor them we're going to love them
they've made some great grown-up
decisions we miss those grandkids so bad
we miss our son we kind of miss your but
not really and
we're going to honor what they're saying
or they're going to throw temper tantrum
but for five years you guys have tried
the same thing you've got to do
something different this is about
boundaries this is about respect this is
about dignity this is about y'all making
grown-up choices and them making
grown-up choices they're big boys and
girls and they did what they did
so did y'all
proud of you for doing what's right for
your family
now you're gonna go into a new season
you're gonna mourn the end of this
fantasy of these magical four
grandparents
and you can deal with the reality
of
two pretty cool grandparents and two who
sometimes act like children
heartbreaking heartbreaking
heartbreaking but that's where we're at
that's reality
let's
let's go let's deal with that story and
go from there thank you so much for your
call sierra thank you so so so much uh i
i was joking at the beginning you're not
the only one everybody deals with this
everybody does with this so thank you so
much for being vulnerable and telling
your story all right as we wrap up
today's show
my boss's boss happened to come through
here
suzanne walked in
and i said hey suzanne
pick the greatest song of all time
pick the song of the day that's actually
what i said i said pick the song of the
day i didn't say of all time
and she said she's been blowing up the
new kanye record
ben that's got your number all over it
it really does
you digging it oh yeah i haven't spent
enough time with it i'm just kidding i
haven't actually listened to it is that
bad
i mean it means you're
you're like my resident hip-hop guy and
so yeah i feel like you failed me but
it's cool yeah wow
i've just heard all the drama around it
i haven't dug into it i need to sit down
and experience kanye records when they
come out i just haven't had time and i
don't have
i have a cd player in my car evidently
they're not making cds anymore except
for john mayer's new record came out on
cassette which was kind of dope don't
have one of those players either but
it's cool so
this one's to you suzanne off the brand
new donda record
kanye west's off the grid and it goes
like this
we off the grid grid grid this for my
kid kid kid for when my kid kid kids
have kids everything we did for the crib
everything we did how we live what all
this smoke got a scent all the smoke
heaven sent sit everything i spoke what
i meant i never disguise my intent lines
outside the event we off the grid
grid grid right here on the dr john
deloney show
you